[Music]
kids often reveal way too much
information about their family life but
the funniest ones come from their
drawings stick around to see one of the
most shocking revelations about a
certain dad's bedroom activity don't
forget to subscribe to our Channel and
give this video a big thumbs up now
let's check out 10 funniest kid drawings
that say a lot about their parents be is
for beer
erm we'd like a few words with the
parents of this child who was asked to
spell something that begins with the
word B other children would probably
reply with things like butterfly bag
balloon and so on and on but not this
kid according to this child B stands for
beer kids usually talk about whatever
they see most at home and it's obvious
that the parents of this child drink
beer and they probably do it much more
than they should we can only assume that
these yellow dots are actually beer
glasses and we hope the kid didn't try
beer and find out what it tastes like
just yet suck it out kids are always
asked all sorts of questions at school
and sometimes they give the absolute
funniest answers although it's not a
drawing we just had to add this one in
because the kid does have a pretty good
point when asked to describe some
positive ways their family handles
stress the kid replied that they suck it
up it really says a lot about the
parenting style in the family doesn't it
the kid does have a point but we really
hope the family does a bit more than
just tell their children to suck it up
and get over their problems drink wine
seriously kids say the darndest things
but sometimes those things reveal a lot
about their parents we've probably all
done this exercise at school where we
have to draw something about our mom or
dad this kid was asked to draw whatever
they think their mom should do less of
the kid drew a couple of hearts but they
also drew a mom with what looked like a
glass of red wine in her hands
underneath it it says they want her to
drink less wine it really makes you
wonder just how much wine does this mom
actually drink it seems like she doesn't
even do it in the evening since the
child's still awake to see it white
world this one doesn't really teach us
anything about the parent because we all
know it was just a typo but imagine if
it actually wasn't a typo did you notice
how this kids filled the world wide it's
a pretty common spelling mistake by kids
but given this context it does look like
the parents haven't really taught their
kids about any other culture other than
their own we do hope that this isn't the
because this whole thing is totally
adorable who would have thought a
spelling mistake like that can totally
change the meaning of the message we do
want to know how that chocolate cake
tasted though it looks absolutely
delicious happy Christmas this is one of
our favorites ever everyone wants to
receive best wishes on Christmas but
this child added a little extra present
to whoever this card was aimed for it
looks like the parents of this kid
didn't have the time to review the
Christmas card before sending it off
because they left the recipient with a
slightly unfortunate message at the
bottom of the note we love the left part
as the kid wishes that the person would
get a lot of presents but it's totally
ruined by the right side of the card
where the kid calls the person fat we
hope that the busy parents have enough
time to reread the Christmas cards their
kid rights problem this one really makes
us laugh out loud because it definitely
shares way too much TMI than it actually
should the kid was asked to answer the
question of who eats the most at a
picnic and we're assuming the question
corresponds to an illustration you can
partially see on the right the kid had
two answers but instead of picking those
they wrote the person that eats the most
is their dad and that he has a real
problem
what a way to out your dad for eating a
lot poor dad we hope they were able to
catch this answer before the child
brought the homework to class mom's
going out it looks like this mom is
living a double life and the child just
exposed her no one likes morning's but
this mom seems to be taking it really
bad and apparently there's a reason for
it on the left side this kid drew a
picture of the mom pretty much out of it
and not really knowing what's going on
but on the right she's ready to go out
looks like she spends more time clubbing
than she does anything else which is
exactly why she looked so out of it each
morning definitely a bit of TMI but we
also hope the mom still a decent parent
when I grow up here's a little preview
of what we'll talk about in another
video there appears to be quite a lot of
drawings where kids share what they want
to be when they grow up in an
inappropriate way but in this case they
managed to reveal something strange
about their mom considering there's a
poll and people with happy faces are
giving money to the person it's safe to
say the mom could be a pole dancer but
why does that kid know what the mom does
in the first place when children would
never be allowed in a club like this
what do you think could it represent
something else the demon okay we have a
few questions about this family and
things they actually see this kid wrote
that they had a fun time with mom dad
and their cat but then they added a
creepy note that even the demon left
them alone this time which means there
were plenty of instances when he didn't
leave them alone seriously who is this
demon and why haven't the parents done
anything about him well maybe they have
since he left them alone for the first
time they hung out creepy but we
definitely have a lot more questions and
we need the answers wrestling but
sometimes kids seriously reveal the most
disturbing things ever check out this
situation described as wrestling by the
child who seems to listen to his dad
shenanigans in the bedroom
the kid says they know that the dad is
winning at wrestling because of the
sounds his partner is making we won't
repeat the name the child calls that
partner but it's safe to say he has
heard way too many things that happen in
that bedroom and if that's not enough
the kid seems to be genuinely excited
that his dad is apparently winning at
the so-called wrestling and let's just
end it on that note because that really
is one of the weirdest drawings ever
that's it for our video don't forget to
subscribe to our Channel and hit that
like button for more videos like this
one see you next time
[Music]